number three  do the opposite of what your instincts  are if you're going to play the game  um it has to be the opposite of what  your instincts in the crowd says because  the market reflects the crowd so  you want to buy when no one wants to buy  and you want to sell when no one wants  to sell right  so and that's emotionally difficult  um and probably you're not going to play  that game well because it takes a lot of  resources to play the i'm we spend  hundreds of millions of dollars each  year to try to play that game well and  it's a tough game to play well so i  would caution you about the market  timing game but i would say that if  you're going to do it do it in the ways  that are uncomfortable because they're  opposite your instincts